you
[Music]
my name is Shalom's if you don't know me
i'm part of the of the are open side
group i UC berkeley this is our art team
and i maintain a lot of our packages
many of them wrapping external libraries
external c and c++ libraries and in
addition I'm also the maintainer of the
windows installers for our base and our
tools and the current talk will be on
the intersection of these two things and
I will go into what's involved with
building our own windows and in
particular how we're gonna try to
improve that for the next generation of
the compiler tool chain all right so
first I'm going to explain a little bit
about how it currently works and what
how our tools currently works and then
in the second part I'll introduce the
new tool chain which is currently
experimental in which we're beta testing
hopefully to be included with the next
major release of our so what's our tools
well to understand that you need to take
a step back so in order to compile
things both base R as well as packages
you need a compiler and on Linux and Mac
OS there is a native compiler in the
system Linux is usually GCC in a mac OS
we have clang with with Xcode but no
windows there's no such thing so on
Windows so we need to we need to provide
our own compiler tool chain and that is
that is our tools so our tools if you've
ever had to install a package from
source so Windows is this thing you
install separately
and it helps you with with building
stuff on windows
there's no timer but that's alright
alright so our tools has been around for
quite a while I didn't invent this as
you can see from this retro 90s homepage
from cran it has an archive of all of
the art tools going back like a decade
or two so this is something that's being
supported for quite a while and I've
only taken over maintenance last year so
please don't blame me for everything
that's suboptimal so what does the
workflow look like so you install this
thing and then you have this
installation dialog in it you can choose
which components you want to install so
there's the tool chains which are like
the most important thing and some built
utilities mostly make and a shale and
tar to extract stuff which are also
needed to install our packages and then
the other things are sort of optional
the last thing is only needed if you
want to build our itself which you
should never do but add you know it's
like clip ICU and tech info and tcl/tk
alright so yeah so this is what I just
said and so to summarize our tools is
needed to build base our and if you want
to build our packages on Windows which
contain C or C++ or Fortran code and
this is the part that most users are
familiar with but then there's also a
very big third thing which is external
libraries so a lot of both base are and
a lot of our packages are using external
system libraries and those system
libraries need to be compiled with the
same tool chain
same configuration as we're using for
besar and that is that is sort of a dark
piece of the ecosystem right now so if
you've seen any of my previous talks
you've maybe seen this picture so this
is what the dependency system looks like
yeah if all of your packages and they
depend on R and R itself depends on like
a lot of external libraries that we all
need to build with the same tool chain
in order to build our for Windows and
many are packages they also depends on
like a bunch of other external libraries
and this is yeah this is a lot of work
to build all these things so currently
we're doing this manually so there's the
or wind lip organization in which we
manually release binaries for like the
most important external c and c++
libraries which are used by cran
packages and and there's currently see
there there's 773 libraries in there
right now but that's not gonna
dependency so you know for example one
one of these libraries can depend dozen
more other sub libraries so there's like
hundreds of external libraries that are
that are in there yeah and this this
this is kind of suboptimal maintaining
these bills is it's a lot of work and if
you want to build our package that needs
any of these libraries it's kind of a
bit of a hack because you know the
packets are stored or the build server
will need to manually download these
lips and then put them in a special
location and then like you know mingle
with the compiler and the linker flags
on your system or you can like have a
script in your package that
automatically downloads them but you
know it's not the way the world supposed
to work so
for the next hour tools I wanted to sort
of improve the situation and looked
around a bit and how order out of the
system in other places so we want to
take advantage of a proper build system
which we can so that we can more easily
build all of these external libraries
using the same compiler tool chain and
the same our tool system as we use to
build our packages or base or itself and
then we want to automate that that build
process and also I would like to open
and collaboratively maintain these
package build scripts so that it's more
easy for other people to contribute a
build script of a new external package
if they want to use it in their heart
package yeah so that is sort of the goal
of our tools for coronel and I want to
emphasize again that this is something
that we're currently beta testing it's
not sure at all if and when it's going
to ship but hopefully it will maybe for
the upcoming release or order otherwise
the one after that yeah so you can
already test it if you go to cran Google
our tools for T there's a special page
and there you can install our tools 4.04
for your system and then there's also a
special version of R which I call our
testing and it's like the art of L
builds if you've ever tried this but as
it has been configured to use this new
tool change so it's sort of hard code at
the path to the new tool chain so these
and it as a custom location where
installs the packages so you can use
this you can install this you can drive
it play with the new art tools and won't
conflict with any other packaged
libraries or so that are using
the current stable tool chain so so
what's the experience like you install
this thing and then certainly in your
Start menu there's this new thing which
wasn't there before because you know
before our tools was just sort of a
bundle that you install operating system
and now there's actually a shell and
there's a that's a thing so like what if
I click on that so if you click on that
it opens a terminal window
so there's actually our tools now
actually includes like a fool terminal
with with with bash shell all of the
tools that you're that you're used to or
probably not the few on windows but if
you it's a full unix-like environment
based on MCS - and cygwin which has you
know all of the all of the build tools
that you need to build all of these open
source libraries so what's tin well the
most important thing is that's a nice
terminal and there's the shell and
everything that comes with that
you know bash and then there's all of
these utilities which are part of
sickling like make and set a parallel
whatnot and of course there's the
there's the compilers there's the mingw
compilers one for 32-bit and one for
64-bit Windows but the most important
thing in newer tools is there's a
package manager and it's a real package
manager to build and install external
libraries you know just like apt on
Debian or on Enterprise Linux or
homebrew on OSX so it's just very so
what would that look like if you the
package manager is go back man and then
the first command back man does S stands
for sync and then why is it things with
the repository index and for example s
why you would upgrade all of the
installed packages and then the second
block of code shows
for example how you would install the
lib XML to package and in in pac-man
there's a separate package for the 32
bit in a 64 bit package but you can
install them both with this syntax and I
want to emphasize I didn't event back
man this is like the package manager for
Mark's lineage which has been ported to
the windows and it's a really nice fit
and it has it's it's really nice it has
all of the features that you want to
explain that you can expect from modern
package manager so it really starts to
feel like a proper operating proper
operating system so I didn't have the
confidence to do a live demo like Gabor
so what does it look like as a shell and
then this is pac-man and if you do
pac-man sy it updates the repository and
here I'm installing the curl package and
it says you know curl depends on the
person's age and open a cell so we need
these things as well so it starts
pulling in these things and it's
installing blah and this is for speed so
slower in real time and then it's done
right and now it's there so now you can
do package skin like a config curl it's
there so it's it's really like like you
would expect from you know from apt or
more so alright so which packages do we
have so there's a repository and there
are - windows are tools packages which
currently contains all of the like I
think about a hundred packages that I've
ordered to this system so this
repository contains all of the the built
formulas for this packages are not the
actual binaries but these are like the
the pacman
config file to build these things and if
you look what's in there every of these
sub directories contains a file called
packets build and that this defines like
the name of the package like the URL of
the source you know a bunch of patches
checksums stuff and you know what's
needed to to build a package and install
the package so usually there's like some
C make or a configure line and then make
and that make install so what does that
look like so for example here's an
example where they're building the
popular package which uses C make to
build you always have to do make package
mingw so if you do that in the directory
that contains this package build file
like everything else automatically done
so it starts pulling in the source for
the popular library it runs see Meg on
all of these things and you get the
output and then you know if everything
works in the end it will it will
compress libraries strip out some debug
symbols and create an actual a package
like which is a [ __ ] or taxi file so run
here it's done and now it's tidying up
the install stripping loads and then you
have an actual our package and the and
the binary package astiz new target dot
X C file that was created right so it's
it's it's once the formula is in place
like maintaining these things is
hopefully gonna be much easier than this
now alright so that is how you do a
manual a bit of course you want to
automate it so if you send a pull
request to this library or in my case if
you
push straight to the master branch
half-fare we'll start building these
things and it looked like this when you
can use and you can look at in a log
file of the affair which are the latest
things that that you've built and this
is sort of the most beautiful part of
the system so it automatically deploys
so if you look in a pure log file
towards the end and if it's if it's if
it's in a pull request or a branch it
will then just say it was complete but
if your master branch
they will then automatically deploy
everything to been trained so all of
these all of the binaries for the for
these windows packages they are hosted
on Ben Tre and they are automatically
deployed once the build is successful
from affair so there's like this nothing
that I have to do other than merging the
pull request to actually release these
libraries right so once you once you
once the bills complete at the bottom
you see it's a player starts uploading
the binaries to Ben ray and it's sort of
recalculating the index file and then
you can see it on this on this URL so
this is the URL where of the all of the
binary package are stored and this is
this is the URL that an pac-man in our
tools uses to figure out the packages so
it's live immediately there's there's no
manual step anymore
you know he said the pull request at for
your bills if it succeeds to deploy some
bin tray and then you know the next time
any user would do pac-man you know as
updates it starts pulling in these new
libraries so it's sort of dice up the
circle
really nicely yeah so I hope that that
this will make the maintenance much
easier and
and I should emphasize that this one
chef installed a one of these sets of
system libraries using pac-man our tools
will automatically find it when you
build an art package that needs a
library so there's no need to set
special compiler flags or special link
effects the point to a particular
location because pac-man stalls it
exactly where the linker expects to find
it and compilers to actually find it
right so it's gonna feel much more like
apt or your brew where you if you need a
system dependency you do do pac-man
install and the system dependencies
there and then your our package should
just build without you know any further
hacking so in summary last slide the new
version of our tools will include like a
proper built environment that will make
it easier for me for us to to build and
external and install all of the external
libraries pac-man will back man makes it
really nice to package and distribute
and install these tips so it's no manual
copying of files anymore and build
server Arnold and automatically find
those installed lips so you don't need
to pass special linker flags or include
flags when you're installing in our
package windows from source and the most
important part is that you know these
libraries are all going to be
transparent and reproducible and how to
made it fear the CIA so there's you know
there's there should be much less
maintenance but also I think that's
going to be a bit more accountability
because currently you know I'm just
uploading these binaries to our Inlet
but you know nobody knows how they are
built and you know what I what I put in
there and like this this system is gonna
it's going to be fully open fully
transparent fully automated and
everything gets built in in a public
place and deployed and you know everyone
can contribute so yeah that's it you
know all the slides below thanks thank
you very much for your talk and also for
making my life so Windows user so much
easier than it would otherwise have been
we have time for one question this
question at the back I think it's rich
here with a golden shirts thanks good
throw
so this sounds like it makes it a lot
easier to have more external
dependencies so are there going to be
some new dependencies that are uses
because it's now easier to have external
dependencies for are there gonna be some
more dependencies in base our exciting
new tools yeah so I hope that that is
that the system will make it easier to
to use to take advantage of these
external libraries in our more easily
because previously you're sort of tied
to what I mean on linux fedora most of
it is available in sorta but on Windows
the system was really limited by you
know people that were willing to build
these things for you and this like only
two of them that would probably do that
so I hope that this will I hope not open
the floodgates but at least give our
users better access to up-to-date
high-quality libraries that now also
work on Windows
[Music]